[Music]
i know that you're an intelligent fellow
you follow the news are you following
this election before we go you know is
there any you want to give your opinions
well tomorrow i think is going to be
really amazing because
even though i'm look i'm an obama
supporter but am objective enough to
know the last debate with him in romney
he got his butt kicked romney was
amazing but now they're doing a town
hall format where romney's got to be in
front of
basically people that he the 47 percent
that he said were freeloaders and
whiners and stuff so he's gonna have to
defend himself so um i you know people
are gonna ask him that question so in
all fairness i could i give romney a
little bit of advice for tomorrow night
i'm sure he's watching
yeah definitely he's watching this um
okay so what i'll be i'll be romney
right now um on jupiter fatter and uh so
i'm gonna need a uh i'll just need a
random question from an audience member
if we could get
governor oswald in a recent interview
you said and i quote
conan o'brien is perhaps the greatest
threat to our country's moral and
cultural well-being
his obsession hearing himself is
overshadowed only by his vapid
self-righteous comedy
that destroys every mind and soul it
encounters
his dental hygiene is deplorable
his body odor is reminiscent of decaying
wet leaves
i personally have witnessed him urinate
on the stoop of over a dozen orphanages
the saddest part is that 47 of our
country has done the same
i i think it's interesting how they've
really dwelled on the negative aspects
of what i said yes i said that conan
o'brien smells like wet rotting leaves
which happens to be
the smell
of autumn
and what is a more beloved delightful
smell than of autumn that's a time of
homecoming games and halloween and a
thursday where we we thank everyone for
all of our blessings so so conan i want
to thank you personally for your
patriotic stench
but also
i loved how the media totally left out
my other positive comments about this
man about how he's a television
personality who understands his
influence on america's children who
right now are going through the biggest
obesity epidemic in this country and yet
he strives to stay thin and cut and
healthy and and not just evolve into
some huge blob that just sits on a couch
spreading and inhaling poho's all day
and
who during every single commercial break
has his own personal pizza flavored
combo pa bring out a mixing bowl full of
snacks that he horks down like a crazed
warthog conan o'brien i salute your
thinness and i want everyone who is
blobby and spreading and pear-shaped to
be wiped off the face of the earth
[Applause]
i i bet you romney doesn't use that
[Laughter]
guess